do you read a lot of manga it's it's
hard because i feel that
the time when i would read manga i'm
normally doing something else
like i've i've seen you like reading
quite a few more i mean you read all of
like
terraformers if i read a manga it's like
non-stop
yeah like i cannot put it down so it's
very like hard for me to get into so i
don't think you'd enjoy then if it's
like a currently
uh serializing yeah i don't read
currently serializing except for one
punch man
yeah because that's always always a
treat whenever it pops up it's like it's
a new chapter i'm like [ __ ] yeah because
like action happens in every chapter oh
my god one punch my monger is [ __ ]
beautiful man yeah this [ __ ] is amazing
yeah
oh i love that [ __ ] and then i tried to
read the web comic but i was like
with the guy taking off the headset he's
like i was like oh
it's funny but it's like the best you
can't you can't go back to the web manga
once you've experienced
that exactly the art is so good and
it [ __ ] blows my mind that the first
season actually managed to capture how
hype his art was oh yeah
and maybe even exceed it at some points
but like his art is [ __ ] insane
i mean i've loved it since i showed 21.
so when i found out he was doing one
punch man i was like beautiful
yes the best i shall 21 is still one of
my
favorite sports manga that's something
i've downloaded to actually
read at some point but it's like every
time i'm going to start a sports manga
it's like slam dunk or eye shield
and then i just i'm like [ __ ] which one
should i choose
just do both man yeah honestly those are
my top two yeah
and though and those are like the two
sports manga that you should definitely
read the sportsman yeah and not watch
the sports anime
because they are they have not aged well
mostly because
their matches take so [ __ ] wrong this
is back in the day of like dragon ball z
yeah i remember
the first time i watched slam dunk and i
remember thinking
why is a match like 10 episodes how can
i how can i possibly
stretch a match over to 10 episodes and
i watch the entirety of the slam dunk
anime and then i read the manga and then
it just felt like when rock lee had
taken off his training ways
like it was moving so fast and i was
like i didn't know i didn't know the
story couldn't move this channel
yeah yeah exactly exactly but uh yeah
like definitely
i think not enough people read sports
manga or sports anime
every single sports anime that i've
consumed i've loved like yo mushy petal
really surprised me i really [ __ ]
love that i
i finally now have an excuse to start
reading haikyuu now that it's finished
i do want to read that because i found
the anime a little boring oh really
yeah no early i've heard i've come i got
half of you the second season and i'm
like
why does it feel like i'm watching
season one
like i just felt like i was watching
season one again like that bad is that
is that a fair taste no i mean
i i feel like it gets better and better
every season because i remember
haiku says that i feel like i'm in the
minority yeah everyone says that yeah
i feel like like i i i was properly sold
in haikyuu like properly properly
into it uh the last match of season two
and then season three came along and
season three is just one match and i
remember thinking to myself
before the season started how can they
make an entire season from just one
match
we're going back into slam dunk
territory yeah
this is way too dragged out and then i
watched it and i'm like
oh my god this is the best season so far
this has taken it to another level but
when i know that it's going to be a full
season what i'm thinking in my head is
like whoa that was amazing but i'm like
[ __ ] i'm not going to find the
conclusion for like 20 episodes
and i i i know roughly what's going to
happen there's a boy's trying to speed
run a sportsman
well i don't know what's going to happen
they don't know the pacing i'm like
great this is awesome like i'm
i'm shocked i don't know like what to
expect if i go into it now i'm thinking
okay i'm gonna get was it twelve
episodes uh it was it was only like nine
episodes so
it was less okay that's good if okay
nine episodes management if it's like 25
and it was like all the season was 25
episodes i'd be like i can't do it i
can't well that's why the slam dunk and
i shield 21 manga is so good because the
pacing in that for every single match is
legitimately like
this could end in two chapters or it
could end in 100 i'm gonna try
reading one of them i want to read manga
on stream i've been trying to
get permission from a company to be able
to yeah yeah i think that would be hard
dude if you if you like do us a stream
where you
read eye shield or slam dunk like i'll
tune into that